we can't really measure distances in  outer space  for short distances all we need is a  ruler or tape measure for longer  distances we might travel the full  length and do a calculation we put a  mirror on the moon for that exact reason  but if a distance is so big that we  don't have access to the other end then  we can't measure it at least not proper  distance when you hear the Crab Nebula a  6500 light years from Earth that's a fib  a light year is the distance light  travels in a year but that's the problem  the 6500 light years isn't the distance  to the Crab Nebula it's the distance  light had to travel from the nebula to  get to earth The Crab Nebula is close  enough that this Nuance isn't an issue  but what about a distant Galaxy like the  galaxies in this Deep Field image that  light takes millions or even billions of  years to get here those Galaxies have  certainly moved by then what we're  really measuring is time because